John is with us in Miami Florida hi John
how are you hi daivam honored to be
speaking with you today
you too sir what's up my wife and I are
debt-free and we are currently except
for our mortgage and our goal at this
point is to pay extra on our mortgage
good the issue that I'm having right now
is with her parents they continually
borrow money off us and more essentially
their emergency fund at this point the
most recent amount was fought in Essex
excuse me in excess of $500 and they do
pay us back what I believe they
mismanaged their money and they rely on
us so my question is do we continue to
lend the money because essentially she
cannot tell them though and it's causing
arguments and a lot of stress in our
marriage so is there any advice you can
offer us sure and is there a right or
wrong answer well there's a right answer
um so how old is she your wife
forty-four okay so she's been out of the
house quite a while and why does she
have trouble telling them no just the
family script her mom or her dad or just
overpair overbearing type people or what
she worries about him a lot they're in a
situation where I believe they have
enough money to make ends meet but they
just don't if they miss manage their
money and um so why do you feel like in
general talk about them I'm asking you
about your wife why do you feel like
your wife doesn't look at them and see
what you see maybe because they're her
parents and I try to put myself in her
shoes and if they were mine but I don't
know what it is within her that she
can't say no and how it affects our
relationship or our core relationship at
this point okay here's what I would tell
her if she was my wife okay this is not
about her parents this is about your
wife that's where the core issue is here
okay enablers which is what she is when
you give a drunk a drink you are
enabling alcoholism you
are assisting the drunk in being an
alcoholic that's what an enabler is okay
enablers are the nicest people you will
ever run into I bet your wife is just
sweet they're kind of like me I think
you're a little bit rough around the
edges I bet your wife is sweet Cheers
that's that's part of the issue yeah
I'll bet yes most enablers are they Jay
and they see this as just that telling
her mother no would just be mean that's
how your wife views it because she's a
sweet person right am i right yep okay
absolutely so if you'll think about it
that way when you're talking to your
wife here's what you need to tell her
honey you're a sweet person and you
think you're being nice but the truth is
if you give a cocaine addict cocaine if
you give a crack addict crack if you
give someone who misbehaves with money
money you are not being nice you are
causing them to continue to harm
themselves
that's not nice at all so most enablers
in a chant in an opera in an effort to
be nice actually end up being very mean
to the people that they supposedly love
because they're just weak you see what
I'm saying and I have sat with enablers
and told them listen if you'll get it in
your head that you're actually harming
them by doing this you'll quit doing it
now once you've done that then your wife
comes over on to the side of I'm gonna
love my parents well which is I'm not
gonna participate in their freaking
insanity that's loving them well if you
got a buddy that's doing cocaine you
don't help him kill himself right right
to love him well would be to help him
walk away from the cocaine correct and
if you got somebody misbehaving with
money it's not nearly as serious as
cocaine but it is still misbehavior
these people misbehave
they're immature they're disorganized
and they've never addressed their stuff
and so if I loved them what I would do
is not continue to give them money
unless it had strings attached like you
have to go through Financial Peace
University and I'm gonna give you this
five hundred dollars I don't want to
loan it to you but in order for you to
get this five hundred dollars you have
to sign up for a Financial Peace
University class and I'll pay for that
too but you have you guys have to learn
to handle money because you've worked
your whole lives you got nothing because
you mishandle you make enough to not be
broke and you mishandle it now that is
an act of love towards them and you
can't do it she has to do it because
you're the Haitian you're the Unison off
to take money from her parents they give
us $50 a month to set aside but that's
essentially us managing their money for
that's four-year-old stuff now do that
with a five-year-old I don't do that
with a grown people you could take over
their whole checkbook and manage it to
them form if they have dementia but they
don't have dementia they have laziness
and disorganization in their maturity
and they need to grow up right yeah now
I'm being brutal okay I'm being very
clear I know and I don't want you to
talk to them this way I want her to talk
to them this way mom and dad I love you
and we will not participate in you not
handling money well anymore so work this
time we're gonna give you the 500 we're
not gonna loan it to you but under want
to stipulations number one we're not
giving you any more this is the last
time it's gonna happen number two you're
gonna go through Financial Peace
University and will be your cheerleaders
and your biggest coach because we want
you to turn this around we're not here
to shake our finger at you and condemn
you but I'm not gonna give a drunk a
drink anymore that's a loving act what
she's doing now is not loving it's it's
it's weakness and she's copying it
copping out she has no courage it's not
loving at all she's just so nice she
won't deal with it so that's how I would
handle it if I were you guys I can tell
you that that will also help you with
your marriage relationship you and your
wife because this is a boundaries issues
what it's called
and her father or her mother whoever it
is that makes the phone calls has become
a travel agent for guilt trips and they
call up and tell her all the things they
used to do for her when she was four and
used that as leverage to remind her that
to be a good daughter she has to give
them money and participate in their
delusional craziness you're right they
do call and she feels guilty if she
doesn't wanna call them you're
absolutely correct now their travel
agent for guilt trips it's exactly what
they did it's a normal pattern man and
so but the trick is you got it you got a
bolster your wife and convince her that
she's not helping them she's hurting
them if she really gets that she'll go
oh I would never hurt my parents no
darling you wouldn't and I'll stand with
you but you're the one that has to talk
to them and tell them and you pay for
Financial Peace University form John
it'll be good for them to have their son
and I'll do that and you give them
another 500 bucks another thousand bucks
I don't mind you helping them but I want
to help them win I don't want to
participate in their losing hold on I'm
gonna have Kelly send you a copy of my
buddy Henry clouts book it's called
boundaries your wife doesn't have any
you guys got to read this book this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]